now since the beginning of the pandemic
you may have avoided getting dental care
because of concerns about
the infections office closures cost of
course there's the pandemic
but putting off dental care for children
could develop tooth decay
bianca holman live this morning to share
some details on a program
looking to help families in need bianca
good morning
hey good morning john so yeah during the
pandemic so many families avoided
going in for their dental appointments
because of those sickness concerns or
because their office may have been
closed but
grab your toothbrush grab your floss we
have got a program for you if you are in
need
that will help ensure that your child's
teeth stay in perfect condition i'm
joined here by dr sullivan thank you so
much so tell us about this new
partnership with unlv and liberty it's
fantastic what we have is this
opportunity to bring your child
in here to the dental school and we can
do an exam
x-rays fluoride profi
which is a cleaning and sealants if your
child needs them we can get them back on
track and back into their
regular habits of dental care yeah and i
know we're supposed to see the dentist
two times a year and of course as a kid
growing up i had my share of cavities
because i loved candy
but what are some tips that you can
recommend to parents because of course
kids are getting up right now
right what can we do on our dino getting
ready for school
give us some tips one of the big
mistakes that people do is they run
straight across like this what we'd
really like you to do
is small circles going around all the
corners
make sure you're getting the back side
and of course make sure you're brushing
your tongue
exactly because that tongue can hold
some of that bacteria there so yes
and also you know again like you said
the circular motions that reminds me of
an electric toothbrush so
if you do have an older kid maybe you
invest in something like that right
yes there's really no way that your your
hand can move as fast as those
electronics so
if you can update and upgrade definitely
an electric toothbrush is a fantastic
choice
all right perfect see if i had you as a
dentist when i was a kid i probably
would have listened
thank you so much so coming up in the
six o'clock hour you know you got to get
x-rays right we got to get x-rays so
we're going to head into that room
and learn more about this dental program
for families and some more tips for our
purple dyno
back to you guys in the studio